au lendemain de l'annoncé de sa
réélection le porte parole de l'armée
tchadienne fait une annonce inattendue
concernant idriss déby le maréchal du
tchad président de la république chef de
l'état chef suprême des armées
idriss deby itno vient de donner son
dernier souffle en dépendant l'intégrité
territoriale sur le champ de bataille
c'est avec une profonde amertume que
nous annonçons au peuple tchadien
le décès ce mardi 20 avril 2021 du
maréchal du tchad idriss deby itno des
suites de ses blessures au front avec +2
79% des voix selon la commission
électorale
idriss déby se diriger vers un sixième
mandat
une élection présidentielle marquée par
le boycott de trois concurrents sur neuf
qui souhaitait ainsi dénoncé la
répression des marches pacifiques de
l'opposition organisées ces derniers
mois
le décès du président tchadien ouvre une
période d'incertitudes dans le pays
un de ses fils mahamat idriss déby a
pris la tête d'un conseil militaire
composée de quinze généraux
l'instance a dissous le gouvernement et
l'assemblée nationale mais promet des
élections démocratiques
après une période de transition de 18
mois de leur côté les rebelles ont
annoncé qu'ils ne comptaient pas stoppé
leur attaque lancée le 11 avril dernier
nous rejetons catégoriquement la
transition nous comptons poursuivre
l'offensive le tchad n'est pas une
monarchie
il ne doit pas y avoir une dévolution de
père en fils ne troupes sont en route
vers n'djamena mais nous laissons 15 à
28 heures pour que les fils de débit
enterrent leurs pairs comme le veut la
tradition du côté de la population
l'annnonce de la transition est
également vu d'un mauvais oeil les
habitants dénoncent un déni de
démocratie et demandent le soutien de la
communauté internationale
c'est imbattable un coup d'état qui les
gens organisés contre la population
ce n'est pas contre le président contre
la population pourquoi parce que le
plaisir vient de décéder automatiquement
les gens oublient la constitution qui
devint qui est bien établie je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui ne va pas se
faire et moi je demande également la
situation au tchad pose également la
question de la stabilité d'une région
toute entière déjà en difficulté face
aux attaques jadistes le président deby
était notamment considéré comme un allié
précieux de la france au sahel